- [Gary] Well, of course.
Of course.
Why do you think I want
them to do it on TV?
Because by the way, I don't
need our discipline to win.
Creative is variable, right?
I'd be thrilled if TV won and
proved out to be a
better medium for them.
I'm thrilled.
Let's see it.
Show me.
(light music)
(partial conversations)
- Gary, I liked our cadence
yesterday of I just tweeted at
you and then you
called me. It was great.
- Sometimes funny things happen.
- Alright, let's do this.
- [Gary] Let's do this.
- [Man] Good, how are you?
- [Gary] What's up, man?
- It's a pleasure.
- How are you?
- Doing well. You?
- Nice to meet you.
- Yeah, great to meet you.
- I'm doing great.
I appreciate it.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- So tell me what's up.
- I'm doing a lot in my little
small world called lacrosse--
- [Gary] Yep.
- but I have been just like
adamant and growing and
through the internet and now in
events and then learning how to
operate as a company I've now
started kind of following you
in a way of doing some angel
investments and now doing more
venture investments
in the tech/sports space.
- [Gary] Using the platform
to take it to the next level.
- It's just the
influencer platform.
- [Gary] Of course.
So let's reverse engineer.
What do you want to happen?
Like in a perfect world in a
decade, what does it look like?
- [Paul] For me?
- Mhmmm.
- [Paul] I think--
'Cause I think that's,
I didn't even,
I talk about it more now
but I'm stunned how
patient and how
focused I've really,
everything I've done has been
towards like if I'm going to buy
a very expensive sports
franchise all my behavior
including massively underselling
this company knowingly a piece
of it to Stephen Ross 'cause he
was an NFL owner and
that would be an important
piece of the process.
- [Paul] Right.
- When you have the humility
and patience to leave tens of
millions of dollars on the table
for what you believe in,
that's when you know you
when you're fucking all in.
- [Paul] Cool.
- Pleasure.
You want to take
a photo you said.
- I enjoyed it.
- That's the most important.
That has grand slam potential.
You could have 2.8 million
followers on Musically.
- [Paul] I have to figure out--
- You can't have 2.8 million
views on Snapchat, you can have
2.8 million views on
Musically in six months.
Figure it out.
- Hotel right at the airport,
wake up and
take a car or would you rather--
- No.
- 45 minutes you
stay in the hotel--
- 100%. I'm already,
I'm all momentum.
So I'd rather go.
- [Tyler] Okay, cool.
I didn't want to
offer that but--
- [Gary] Offer that.
If they come and see me
Friday in the Hamptons,
I'll 100% see them.
- Okay, cool.
- [Gary] If they don't,
I can't guarantee it yet.
- [Man] So I always have two
questions, one is what is not
happening here that
you want to happen here?
Where can I sort of insert
myself or even just a
large team as a whole,
where can we build ourselves
out to make your vision happen?
- [Gary] The normal answer to
that question is a lot more
tactical. It's these specific
principles or revenue,
they're tactical. I don't give
a shit about that.
That will happen in due time.
This is a company
that in five years has
gone from 30 to 650 people.
We know what the
fuck we're doing.
What's not happening
here is something
that's very important to me.
What's not happening here is
that we have 615, 650,
it's fluctuating, people and
not every single one of them
realizes that this is an
all-time special place.
And that's what I want fixed.
In a world where out of 615
I feel like there's 150, 200
people that are out
and out all bought in.
That's far from
where I want it to be.
The fact that there is 100
people that are struggling and
don't like it and may not
like it, that breaks my heart.
And then there's 300
that are and I want,
I don't think people realize
what's actually happening here.
Good.
- Thank you so much.
- [Gary] Yeah.
I wish you well.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Yeah, I'm ready.
(light music)
When? Yeah.
Okay.
- So I had us and
Revlon that day.
New bid.
(light music)
- [Gary] Yo.
- [Everybody] Hey!
- 'Sup guys?
- What's happening?
- [Gary] 'Sup?
How are you guys?
Is data sciences his entire
backbone based on an eraser
board that says do not
erase that anybody can erase?
- Yes.
- Have a great day guys.
Can somebody get
Tyler to get my phone?
Can you get me my phone?
Hey.
- How's it going?
- [Gary] Really
good, how are you?
- Good.
I was on your
Instagram yesterday.
- I know.
You saw my Beyoncé post.
- Yes, because I was there.
(light music)
- Three years.
- Is that true?
- Second.
- The first time in my
office and this is the second?
- Yeah.
- That's it?
- It feels like yesterday.
- I feel like our courtship at
SXSW six years ago felt like a
good amount of
time so maybe that.
(laughter)
Well, cool.
The first part is look I think
one of the great ways to build a
relationship with me and I'm
sure everyone else on earth is
like post game results
and things of that nature.
It's super impressive
what you're up to.
I'd love to dig a little bit
deeper and understand
where you're at.
I have a lot of thoughts
(censored) on to the next level
and thrilled to
talk to you about it.
I'll probably need some
questions answered so I can
actually give you some value.
The 45 people,
the 17 people that really
run your company with you,
the seven you need
to know everything.
You need to have dinner with
them. You need to give a fuck.
The biggest mistake
people make
is not having
real relationships,
tough conversations,
easy ones,
having the ability to
have years, like, years,
a year where it's not
black-and-white, then good years.
That's a big, big piece of
advice that I think people are
gonna lose on.
- [Man 2] That would be good.
- [DRock] I agree.
- Yeah. Alright.
- [Man 3] How we doing, sir?
- Really good, man.
It's good to see you again.
- [Man 3] Last time I got to say
hello to you was in the airport
at Turks and Caicos
a couple years ago.
- I remember that, brother.
That was really funny.
- (inaudible) was like,
"Who the hell is that guy?"
I said, "Don't worry about it.
You'll never get it."
(laughter)
- [Gary] I remember that, man.
That little tiny airport.
I love losing.
- [Man 3] I heard you
say that the other day.
- I fucking love losing.
You can't win as an entrepreneur
unless you love to lose.
- [Man 3] I love and I hate it.
- [Gary] Well listen
I mean, of course.
Of course.
Anybody watching this
or hears that quote,
I get 400 fucking emails,
the amount of fucking emails
I get when people are like,
"You're wrong
GaryVee, losing sucks."
I'm not wrong,
you don't understand.
If you're scared of
the game, you've lost.
I'll never be a good dancer
because I'm scared of what
I look like when I dance.
I know what this is about.
If you are scared,
you have lost.
Don't even start.
That's why I don't, I'm not
trying to go to hip hop class
and get better.
It's not going to
happen, I'm scared of it.
Absolutely.
- [Man 3] Listen ever
run our--
- [Gary] I will. I'm hundred
percent going to stop by.
- Let me know,
I would love that.
We'll set something up.
- [Man 2] So I had
to get you this.
- [Gary] Dude, this
is fucking awesome.
This is somebody who's
paying attention to my world.
This is a meaningful gift.
These headphones, I love it.
Thanks guys.
Take care, man, stay well.
Hey. How are you doing?
- Really well.
- Really good.
What's that?
Call? Where's the call?
In here or?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- Are incredibly important.
(light music)
- It's just a funny thing to say.
- [Zak] There's going to be a
lot of people who about to
be disappointed when they're
not going to reach what they
consider being successful.
I want to make sure that we
are starting to have a real
conversation about
these expectations.
It's too common for people to
think that they have to make or
raise millions of dollars to be
a successful business person.
- 'Sup Pam?
Hey Pierce. Nice sneaks.
'Sup Alex?
Do you play tennis?
- No, I used to
when I was little.
- You should play Tyler.
- No, I cannot play.
- [Tyler] Forehand is nice.
- Yours?
- [Tyler] Oh yeah.
- [Gary] Can you play?
- [Tyler] Fuck yeah.
- [Gary] No way.
- [DRock] I'll beat you.
- [Gary] You can play tennis too?
You guys are real
tennis players?
- [Tyler] I can play tennis.
- I'm not.
- [Woman] Congrats on the house.
- House is amazing. Congrats.
(woman on street sneezes)
Bless you.
- [Woman 2] Thank you.
- You doing okay?
- [Gary] I'm better than good.
Allison, don't
get crazy tonight.
(laughter)
- [Woman On Phone] She's
been sitting by the phone
to hear from you.
If you could call
it would be amazing.
- Oh God.
Missed it.
Use my replay.
- [Woman On Phone 2]
Okay so no way, right?
- Hello?
- [Woman On Phone 2]
Hello, how are you?
- I'm very well, how are you?
- [Woman On Phone 2]
I am like fantastic.
- Are you having a good day?
- [Woman On Phone 2] Yes.
Close the door.
(laughter)
I'm having a great day.
Get out of here.
- I just wanted to say hello
and I appreciate you paying
attention to my stuff
and I'm thankful and
I hope you're doing great.
- [Woman On Phone 2]
I love your stuff.
Thank you so much for putting
all that you put into it.
Honest to God.
- I wanted to say hey and
hope you have a great day.
- [Woman On Phone 2]
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
Bye-bye.
- [Woman On Phone 2] You're
awesome, talk to you later.
- I promise you,
Jordan, we will meet.
Thank you so much, my friend.
Have a good day.
- GaryVee!
- Yes.
- How are you?
- [Gary] Good. How are you?
- Good.
- Good to see you.
- Dan Golden,
I met you like, I don't know,
five years ago.
- It's a pleasure man.
- Conference in Chicago.
- Awesome man, how you doing?
- I'm doing well.
- Good.
The quintessential, can
I get a selfie with you?
- Yeah. No worries man.
Were you heading out?
- I'm headed to
actually just headed in.
I'm going to Google
event right here.
Let's see how this works.
- [Gary] Awesome, man.
- [Dan] Thanks, man.
- Real pleasure.
- I appreciate what you do.
- Good to see you.
I think I'm speaking
at this thing.
- [Announcer] Please join me in
providing a very warm
welcome to Gary.
Thank you very much.
(applause)
- [Gary] Thank you.
My mom would be so pumped
if she was sitting here.
(laughter)
- Thanks for having me.
I think what would be fun is
maybe I'll do a little spiel,
a little context of where I come
from in detail that I think
actually brings you value instead
of just spewing old facts and
then, honestly, since it's such a
small room I'd love to do Q &amp; A
if you guys want to talk about
that if there's anything that
I speak about right
now that brings value.
Every time I speak I try to
reverse engineer the room,
try to understand
what people in
the room would
actually care about
and so I think to that bio the
thing that would be interesting
in this room is that when I took
over my dad's liquor store it
was called "Shoppers Discount
Liquors" I rebranded it to
"Wine Library"
and this was 1996.
I launched the site in 1996,
I took over in 1998.
From '98 to 2003,
in that five-year window,
the business was doing
$3 million a year
in top line revenue,
10% gross profit
so $300,000 before expenses
which meant not only did I build
it from three to $60 million in
sales in five years during
that time which was a very young
internet for the people that
have been around,
I did it with no money.
I think the one difference
that continues to sit in my head
compared to what I think is
going on in the ecosystem is
I'm completely agnostic to the
platform where one markets.
I recognize that
creative is the variable.
I'm obsessed the context of the
platform to create the variable.
But I think there's an enormous
amount of romance and tradition
and things that
people hold on to.
I'm okay when it's in the
best financial interest
of that person.
At least that makes
sense to me. Right?
I get more weirded out when
it's literally just ideological.
And this is the way that it
used to be or the way that
I'm comfortable with it being.
And so what I mean by that is
I've come to sum up what I do
for a living by saying that
I think now day trade attention.
In 2009, I started VaynerMedia
because I thought that social
media was going to get
misbranded and it has.
I would sit here and tell you
that I think social media is the
single worst branded
thing in the world.
And what I mean by that is
for all of us in this room,
me included, in our ecosystem
and in the world's ecosystem,
definitely in the marketing
world, social media too all of
us and to our clients is a
footnote, a sprinkle,
an afterthought.
Everybody here if you're here
is smart enough to take one step
back and deploy common
sense and if I ask you
"What is social media?"
"What sites make up this term?"
I think we would all agree
they are the sites that
dominate this device.
I view social media as the
current state of the internet.
Thank you.
(applause)
- [Man 4] Fantastic.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Announcer] Thank
you very much again.
Ladies and Gentleman,
enjoy your dinner.
(crowd chatter)
(light music)
- [Gary] Thanks for having us.
- [Doorman] You're welcome.
- I'm getting an uber.
- [Driver] My first
day on the job.
Where may I take you?
- [Gary] Is that right?
- [Driver] It is.
- [Gary] That's awesome,
man, congrats.
Well, that's fine.
I'm super comfortable with that
conversation because if you're
testing one TV execution against
one Facebook execution
that's a very viable outcome.
And how much in
creative and all that?
So I mean what do
they want me to do?
Tomorrow Bridg, do
they want me to explain?
Do they want me
to give them ammo?
Do they believe that this is
the right execution for them?
(light music)
- 'Sup buddy?
- 'Sup man?
- 'Sup brother?
Good to see you.
How are you?
- Good.
- How are you?
- [Gary] The thing I find
fascinating about
reverse engineering is
if you know where you're
going you have a better
chance of getting there.
(light hip hop music)
You know, if you've
been following my
stuff over the last three, four
years especially the last couple
years I speak about reverse
engineering all the time.
It's just it's how my brain
works and I truly believe
it's how a lot of the
people that win do things.
I do think it's massively
important to know what you're
trying to accomplish first,
not waver from that,
make that the North Star,
cut out all the
other bullshit,
know it's black-and-white,
forget the gray,
forget the distractions,
forget the what if's,
forget the subjectiveness and
address the finish line and
then reverse engineer it.
When you know what you want,
when you know where you're going
and you are not emotional about
it and you don't care what other
people think and you don't get
distracted, you can get there if
you focus on it
24/7/365 forever.
And so I just always
want to always know
what the hell I'm focused on.
And where I'm going.
What I want to do and how do
I want it and within what budget
and how and how many,
it's just reverse engineer
what you want to happen.
The problem for so many of you,
the reason so few things are
happening for a lot of
people is they're confused.
They don't know what they want.
They want 8,000 things.
They're just confused.
Stop being confused.
Figure out what you want,
reverse engineer it and get it.
(light hip hop music)